it's not your job to question us
you are here only to watch
the watch is to last two weeks
we are proposing eight hour shifts there
is to be no conferring between the two
of you
on the 14th day you will each present
your separate testimony may I ask
gentlemen no one has told me what
precisely is wrong with the girl
Anna O'Donnell doesn't eat
how long exactly has it been since the
last time the girl ate
four months
that's impossible
thumbs up
and eyes wide open
are you nervous at all why should I be
nervous
do you know the dangers of a prolonged
fast Anna and only choice I live a
manner
from heaven and how does that feel
full
Anna is in danger
she's an actress
are you feeling well in yourself Anna
very well father thank you
all right does a stranger have to come
between child and his people I'm happy
to find out the truth
I am begging you you must stop the watch
it was a terrible mistake to bring a
nurse here in English
will you help me
this is
[Music]